THIS BED.
>> Tucker: THIS IS A FOX NEWS
ALERT, A SIXTH BOMB BLAST
APPEARS TO HAVE HIT AUSTIN,
TEXAS.
POLICE AND FIREFIGHTERS ARE
RESPONDING RIGHT NOW TO A
REPORTED PACKAGE EXPLOSION IN
THE SOUTH PART OF THE CITY.
AT LEAST ONE PERSON REPORTEDLY
IS HURT, WILL SUPPLY FURTHER
DETAILS THE SECOND THEY COME IN.
AUSTIN POLICE HAVE SHUT DOWN A
CITY STREET AND ANOTHER PART OF
TOWN OVER SUSPICIOUS PACKAGE
APPARENTLY IT'S IN AN APARTMENT
BUILDING.
WHAT DO WE KNOW ABOUT THE
EXPLOSIVES THAT HAVE BEEN USED
IN THIS BOMB?
JOHNNY JOEY JONES JOINS US
TONIGHT.
THANKS FOR COMING ON.
FROM WHAT WE KNOW PUBLICLY ABOUT
THESE BOMBS, WHAT DOES THAT ADD
UP TO FROM WHAT YOU'VE BEEN TOLD
UP TO FROM WHAT YOU'VE BEEN TOL
TOLD?
>> IT'S REALLY HARD RIGHT NOW.
I THINK WHAT THE POLICE ARE
SHOWING AND ASKING THE PUBLIC
FOR INFORMATION IS VERY GENUINE
AND TELLING.
I SAY VERY CONNECTED TO THE BOMB
TECH COMMUNITY AND THERE'S NOT A
LOT OF INFORMATION OUT THERE, SO
THE POLICE ARE KEEPING WHATEVER
THEY HAVE PRETTY TIGHT-LIPPED.
TAKE THE ONE TRIPWIRE OR
COASTLINE OR WHATEVER YOU CALL
IT ASIDE, EVERYTHING ELSE IS
CONSISTENT AND A SENSE THAT IT'S
PUT INTO A PACKAGE AND EITHER
PLACED OR SHIPPED, SO THAT'S THE
ONE CONSISTENT THING OTHER THAN
THE AREA THAT WE HAVE TO GO ON.
THERE'S ENOUGH INFORMATION ON A
TYPE OF EXPLOSIVE OR HOW THEY'RE
WIRED UP AND SET OFF FOR US TO
MAKE ANY KIND OF ASSUMPTION OR
PRESUMPTION ON WHERE THEY'RE
COMING FROM.
I CAN SEE CERTAIN CIRCUITS AND
SAY, IRAQ, AFGHANISTAN, TELE
BAND, ISIS OR I CAN SEE A PIPE
BOMB AT THE DOMESTIC HOMEGROWN.
RIGHT NOW, WE DON'T HAVE ENOUGH
OF THAT INFORMATION TO KNOW.
>> Tucker: WE'VE HEARD THE
BOMBS AS INCREASINGLY
SOPHISTICATED AND THAT WAS
PARTICULARLY APPLIED TO THE
BOMBS DETONATED WITH A TRIPWIRE.
WITHOUT GIVING ANYTHING AWAY,
GIVE US SOME PERSPECTIVE, IS
THAT A SOPHISTICATED DEVICE?
>> THAT'S REALLY SIMPLE.
IF YOU THINK OF A CLOSE LINE OR
YOUR CLOTHESPIN AND PUT A PIECE
OF RUBBER OR WOOD IN BETWEEN IT,
THEN YOU RUN A WIRE FROM THAT,
YOU TRIP OVER THAT, AND THAT
SPRING PULLS IT DOWN.
IT'S REALLY, REALLY SIMPLE.
THE POINT BEING, WHAT WE ARE
SEEING TODAY WITH SOMEONE
SHIPPING A PACKAGE, THAT TAKES A
LOT OF THOSE.
EVERYTHING I'VE HEARD UP UNTIL
LAST NIGHT SEEMED LIKE PRETTY
SIMPLE MECHANICAL ENGINEERING.
YOU CAN USE A WASHING MACHINE
TIME OR SHE CAN GET AWAY, REALLY
QUICK AND WHAT WE CALL SUREFIRE
TECHNIQUE.
TO PUT SOMETHING IN THE MAIL, TO
HAVE IT THROWN AROUND, PUT IN A
TRUCK, ON A CONVEYOR BELT BEFORE
IT GOES OFF, THAT'S SOMETHING
MUCH MORE SOPHISTICATED AND
QUITE HONESTLY, MUCH SCARIER.
>> Tucker: DOES IT SUGGEST A
DIFFERENT KINDS OF EXPLOSIVES?
>> NO.
THERE'S TWO TYPES OF SCIENCE,
THERE IS THE CHEMISTRY AND THE
EXPLOSIVE.
THAT CAN BE BINARY LIKE ALUMINUM
WON'T SAY, BUT YOU CAN GET IT,
OR IT CAN BE CHEMISTRY
INTENSIVE, SO THAT'S ONE PART OF
THE SCIENCE AND THE OTHER PART